one common Trend about this young
generation is they're very uncomfortable
with discomfort when something gets
uncomfortable they would rather quit or
leave than manage discomfort and we see
this manifest in very strange ways um in
the private sector for example multiple
stories of young people who are so
uncomfortable with the idea of having a
confrontation with their boss when I say
confrontation I mean like asking for a
raise like they're so uncomfortable with
the the thought of asking for a raise or
the fear of being declined for that
raise that they quit they quit their job
instead of asking for the that they
think they deserve and usually in
spectacular fashion with an email that
says you don't value me um because I
want more money and so I think teaching
people teaching young people how to be
uncomfortable is a big is a big part of
it and the question is well how do you
do that and that goes to part two which
is you can much more easily manage
discomfort when you feel like you have
somebody to the left of you and to the
right of you who cares about you and
that's another challenge for young
Generations which is they seem for
various reasons which we can or don't
have to get into but they seem to
struggle with forming deep meaningful
relationships the phone is a big part of
it and The Addictive qualities of social
media are a big part of it I think to
contextualize what they're going to get
as opposed to them just going through it
and then us playing defense um for us to
prepare them that this will be
uncomfortable this will be difficult but
here's what you're going to get by
helping them understand the context and
helping them understand that the
relationships they build and how they
learn to rely on each other to manage
the discomfort not only makes them a
more independent group as a group but
it'll be a skill set that will leave
them with a huge Advantage um for the
rest of their lives and so I think it's
really about empathy and understanding
the characteristics of each generation
again not in terms of good or bad or
right or wrong in terms of different and
understanding when those things are
advantages and disadvantages